we all know what that sound means
your mobile phone is interfering with
another wireless device so you turn it
off
but why computers household devices or
broadcast equipment
all electrical devices that use radio
frequencies
meps want to impose safety standards on
the industry to make sure that devices
don't interfere with each other
and to revise a law that dates back to
99. it's mainly in the directive for the
small and medium-sized companies
to have a reliable standards
and of course it is useful for the
consumers
waste is also a big issue we hold around
1 billion useless charges that are out
of date and waiting to be thrown out
one of the big changes meps voted on a
universal phone charger
you change your mobile phone to a
different brand
then you have a game to buy two or three
chargers
so we want one universal charger for
mobile phones
and then you can use it for all the
mobile phones you buy in future
from different companies phones cameras
mp3 players all use
micro usb ports reducing the industry's
environmental footprint could be a good
idea
but what if technology was a leap
forward to say solar-powered technology
then what well i mean you're still going
to have a charger on you and i mean i
think it's partly the connection of the
charger it's part of the voltage that
you use
so um so if you have um
you know you know universal
interconnections
and charging systems and that means if
you buy a solar charger which could
probably be more expensive that means
you can use it for a number of phones
so it seems to be more valuable for that
not less meps at the internal market
committee's meeting on thursday
also approved electronic labeling a vote
on the draft report is expected at the
plenary in
january